[Musique]
cette taxe les feux en californie en
australie les inondations en alberta et
au québec
l'érosion des berges en gaspésie en
nouvelle écosse 8 canicule qui
s'enchaînent
c'est peut-être aussi les images des
villes confiné en temps de pandémie
les craintes d'une crise économique on
dirait que depuis quelques années ça
sent plus la fin du monde que la coupe
stanley ça fait super longtemps que les
humains on part que le ciel leur tombe
sur la tête
sauf qu'actuellement ce sont des
scientifiques des philosophes les
économies des adolescents des enfants
mais marie citoyens et citoyennes qui
martèle le même message
si on continue comme ça l'humanité court
à sa perte
on commence à se demander c'est
parfaitement
[Musique]
notre maison brûle nous ne pourrons pas
dire que nous ne savions pas en est
confronté de manière accélérée et
régulière à des phénomènes qui nous
rappelle de notre mode de vie
au printemps 2001 le mot collapse au
logis est apparu dans le petit robert
pour nommer l'étude la possibilité d'un
effondrement de la civilisation
industrielle
c'est l'ingénieur agronome pablo serving
qu'il a inventée il ya cinq ans en
publiant avec son collègue raphaël
stevens le livre comment tout peut
s'effondrer depuis la collecte au logis
a fait beaucoup jaser surtout en france
ils fonderont c'est pour deux
générations vous moi nous allons le
vivre ce n'est pas ici une sorte de
fantasme catastrophiste c'est une
analyse géostratégique élémentaire je
n'ai plus peur maintenant de parler de
fin du monde
on s'entend là collapsus est pas une
science à part entière c'est un courant
de pensée qui s'appuie sur la science
qui vise à rassembler les conclusions
plusieurs disciplines scientifiques
comme la biologie la climatologie
les séances de l'énergie ou même
l'économie depuis plus de 50 ans
maintenant des travaux de recherche
s'accumulent pour souligner une
contradiction fondamentale de notre
civilisation
nous vivons dans un monde fini
ressources limitées et pourtant nous
visons une croissance économique infinie
une phase assez limité
les collègues se base sur le fait que
l'humanité utilise les ressources de la
terre un rythme qui est insoutenable
pour les écosystèmes
il avance que si un grand nombre
d'espèces animales et végétales
disparaissent la surface du globe
si on épuise les ressources dont on a
besoin pour vivre comme l'eau le pétrole
et certains minerais
si on réussit pas à diminuer notre
consommation d'énergie fossile et qui
est changement climatique s'emballe en
ajoutant tout ce le fait qu'on dépend
des grands réseaux de change commerciaux
qui sont régulés par une économie qui
s'est montrée fragile encore tout
récemment
bref pour eux si tout ça ça arrive on va
se retrouver avec un effondrement sur
libre une situation critique
l'approvisionnement en nourriture en
électricité les soins de base vont être
difficiles à fournir pour une large part
de la population avec tous les conflits
que ça pourrait engendrer les
collectionneurs pense que assez
d'indicateurs dans rouge pour que ça
arrive de leur vivant pour la plupart
c'est difficile d'avancer une date mais
il y en a certains qui se mouiller un
peu plus trop de pollution trop de
changements climatiques trop de perte de
biodiversité
donc dans 50 ans disons dans 15 ans tout
ça va finir par péter il ya aussi des
cas l'absolu qui pensent que la pandémie
c'est juste un aperçu d'un effondrement
qui pourrait avoir déjà commencé
ok c'est quand même vrai qu'il ya des
scientifiques d'une foule de domaines
qui nous disent depuis un certain temps
quel avenir et pour tout à fait rose
partout sur la planète
ils peuvent faire des prédictions des
projections d'ailleurs les rapports sur
le climat à propos du réchauffement
actuel les rapports qui ont été publiés
dans les années 80 se sont révélés quand
même assez juste jusqu'à maintenant mes
yeux personne ne peut prédire l'effet
combiné de plusieurs catastrophes ou de
plusieurs situations très complexes et
encore moins un effondrement
ce qu'on sait c'est que demain un impact
certain sur le climat la biodiversité et
même géologie de la par certains
scientifiques nomme large et aux
logiques actuelles l'anthropocène c'est
à dire marquer par l'humain
si on peut pas prédire un effondrement
on peut quand même étudier ce qui se
sont produits dans le passé
en gros on peut dire qu'à peu près
toutes les sociétés passé ont disparu se
sont effondrés n'ont pas été durable sur
le long terme
l'intrus mère déjà traversé des périodes
de changement que ce soit température
aux conditions climatiques vraiment très
très important sur des périodes bref
donc on est capable en tant qu'espèce de
surmonter ces défis là pour l'humanité
en l'espèce homo sapiens je suis
relativement optimiste on est plus
nombreux qu'on l'a jamais été même si
palais que du jour au lendemain
75 % de la population disparaissent ça
serait terrible on s'entend sauf que
l'espèce elle même survivre mais si on
pense au niveau de réserves et tout ce
qu'on a en termes d'expériences
culturelles dans l'humanité ça ça risque
d'être plus rock'n roll dans les
prochaines décennies
mecha l'absolu ces bases eux aussi sur
des données du passé pour penser à la
fin du monde tel qu'on connaît est-ce
qu'il ya certaines grandes lignes des
circonstances récurrentes qui reviennent
quand on étudie ses différentes sociétés
l'ex ont disparu généralement c'est une
combinaison de surexploitation des
ressources disponibles mais aussi d'un
système politique économique qui est
imposée généralement dues aux verts
là le reste de la société et qu'on
continue à maintenir en place même quand
on commence à percevoir que il ya des
problèmes d'exploitation ou de
surexploitation
parce que c'est la seule chose à
laquelle on est habitués ou parce que
certains des gens qui détiennent les
leviers du pouvoir veulent se maintenir
en place et sont pas directement affecté
par ces carences là il ya beaucoup de
gens qui utilisent des meilleurs comme
exemple d'une civilisation qui se serait
effondré pas tellement qu'ils avaient eu
une civilisation maya mais y avait de
nombreuses cités et omeyer qui ont connu
des périodes d'apogée de déclin de façon
successive archéologiquement nous ce
qu'on voit si souvent des avants après
on voit rarement le le switch ou le
basculement lui-même ce qui fait que
c'est facile de tout percevoir comme des
révolutions ou des effondrements ou des
disparitions
mais pour monsieur et madame tout le
monde dans le passé si souvent pas si
dramatique que ça parce que la personne
individuelle est en mesure généralement
de s'adapter à une nouvelle circonstance
pablo serving a lui-même avoué qu'elle -
fondremand ça résonne plus forts dans
nos têtes que ce qu'ils imaginent
lui-même mais plutôt qu'une fin du monde
tout s'écroule tout d'un coup il ya
plusieurs cas d'absolue qui pensent que
les crises à venir vont venir affecter
certains secteurs de nos sociétés rendre
certaines populations encore plus
vulnérables à des moments précis
il pense aussi qu'on se dirige vers un
futur où les crises vont s'enchaîner de
plus en plus rapidement mais les
colossaux c'est pas juste des
intellectuels du théorise l'effondrement
c'est aussi devenu un mouvement qui
rassemble de plus en plus de gens sur
les réseaux sociaux surtout en france
mais aussi au québec c'est des gens qui
sont souvent très critique par rapport
au capitalisme qui dénonce les limites
d'un monde industrialisé et qui aimerait
en sortir mais dans une volonté de mise
en commun des savoirs et des ressources
et pour que personne ne soit laissé
derrière à quel point l entraide ça fait
partie de la souris
ce qu'on voit dans le registre
archéologiques ou en fait les leçons
qu'on voie dans la plupart des cas dans
le passé c'est plutôt de d'exister au
sein d'un réseau social relativement
étendue un réseau social qu'on va pas
nécessairement exploiter ou explorer
quotidiennement aux mêmes annuellement
mais qu'on sait qu'il est ce qui fait qu
en sorte que lorsqu'il ya un dérèglement
des conditions locales on est en mesure
de faire appel à un cousin au 2e degré
qui vit ailleurs et de pouvoir justement
à les rejoindre ces gens là où
s'inspirer de leur solution sans que le
tissu social soit déchiré par ses
déplacements
c'est justement cette capacité de
pouvoir s'accrocher ou s'atteler à une
variété de comportements une variété de
ressources une variété de groupes
sociaux qui nous permet de développer
une résilience l'entr'aide la
collaboration s'est fondamentalement ce
qui fait de nous des êtres humains
la collecte au logis est à la fois
stimulante et angoissante
c'est facile de tomber dans la peur
quand cinq formes assez sérieusement sur
l'état de la planète en même temps qu'à
l'action permet à certaines personnes
inquiètes de se rassembler d'échanger à
propos d' objectif de décroissance
d'autonomie et souvent ça se fait en
commençant tout simplement pas remettre
les mains dans la terre
oh
dans le prochain volet de notre série on
nous présente des personnes qui ont
transformé leur vie au contact de la
collection logis les gens qui ont
presque abandonné le travail rémunéré
qui sont en quête d'autonomie et qui
souhaitent sortir du système
c'est carbone ouvre un dossier sur la
collection c'est aussi parce qu'on aime
les sauts vous entendre l'action est ce
que vous aussi la pandémie vous fait
réfléchir à ces enjeux là quand vous
pensez à la fin de notre monde est au
début d'un nouveau
qu'est-ce que ça il va quand vous de l'
angoisse de l'incrédulité
un gros regret on aimerait vraiment seul
savoir
écrivez nous un commentaire ou à notre
adresse courriel